[Music]
this man is on a mission to protect sea
life that is under threat his
discoveries have shocked the scientific
world by pioneering the latest
technology he hopes to save some of the
rarest creatures on the planet
like the giant sea bass a monster of the
deep that can grow to nearly 3 meters
long and swallow a medium-sized shark in
one gulp they're the closest thing you
can get to being extinct with only 500
giant sea bass left in the ocean could a
Facebook for fish help bring them back
from the brink of extinction technology
is both the genesis of the problem and I
think an important part of this solution
[Music]
Douglas McAuley is a professor of marine
sciences at the University of California
Santa Barbara he's on his way to the
Channel Islands of the coast of
California
this unique and delicate ecosystem was
made into a network of marine protected
areas parts of the ocean where fishing
is restricted or banned many scientists
believe that creating more of these
areas could be key to saving some of the
thousands of marine species currently at
risk of disappearing forever the giant
sea bass used to thrive along the
pacific coast but sport fishing and gill
net fishing have decimated the
population last year ninety seven of
them were sold in California alone
that's one-fifth of the current
population all around the world advances
in technology are allowing fishermen to
go further and deeper than ever before
we're in a pretty serious point now for
the future oceans well what I see is an
opportunity in the midst of all this bad
news we have more science that is
telling us how to react to these threats
than we've ever had before
marine-protected areas currently make up
3.7 percent of the ocean but critically
endangered fish like the giant sea bass
don't respect these borders
Doug's work is helping to establish
where else and why fishing should be
banned or restricted while also putting
down a baited underwater camera and
trying to collect some of those images
of giant sea bass if they're in the area
of course they are rare but just hope
luck is with us today
conventional tagging methods are hard to
use with rare species like the giant sea
bass so to track them Doug has developed
a novel alternative he's building a
photographic database that can map their
locations a kind of Facebook for fish
this is the baited remote underwater
camera it's focused here on our bait
cage we'll get this guy set up and ready
to go
[Music]
these cameras are carefully lowered into
the depths where they'll be constantly
recording in a bid to capture a glimpse
of one of these enormous and elusive sea
creatures it's a magical experience when
you look down beneath your fins and
there is wildness you have these
hundred-foot fronds they'll grow from
the bottom to the surface leaking
through the canopy of this kelp forest a
rays of sunlight it really feels like an
underwater Cathedral every time I go in
there I'm blown away that's what a
marine protected area is about about
creating a legacy so that that
inspiration is there for generations to
come
Doug's work tracking the movement of
marine species has already had a major
impact one of his research projects
informed the US government's decision to
expand America's largest marine
protected area we used tags like this
and a study of a shark species called a
grey reef shark which as the name
suggests people always thought lived on
coral reefs put this tag on lo and
behold this shark actually was traveling
way out into the open ocean they were
feeding out in these blue plastic sounds
and the protected areas that we'd set up
for them we're too small so it's a
really great example of how a piece of
technology when you strap into a shark
it can tell you how to be smarter at
setting up protected areas after his
success with GPS for sharks
Doug hopes that his Facebook for giant
sea bass could lead to similar results
if he discovers they're populating other
parts of the ocean he can build a case
to create new marine protected areas and
again it's a piece of technology that
could make the difference back in the
lab Doug is reviewing footage from
recent dives here coming out of the
corner another giant sea bass coming in
so close he can actually see the
parasites in its head interestingly this
guy's got some scars on his pectoral fin
at a fishing line hanging
of him that's a guy who has a hook there
that it will be large dense JA helping
to analyze these images is an algorithm
originally developed by NASA to identify
stars but Doug and his team are now
using it to identify fish on both sides
of a giant sea bass there are spots and
those spots are unique accidentally
these giant sea baths are carrying their
own barcode on the sides of their bodies
the algorithm can quickly scan an
identified individual fish so far Doug
has catalogued 115 of this critically
endangered species and is mapping their
migration patterns we know next to
nothing about giant sea bass a project
like this gives us the raw data to
actually manage their future successful
in marine scientists are increasingly
turning to technology and data to help
reverse the damage being done to our
ocean and to endangered species like the
giant sea bass we need to see more
people like me that are fish nerds
hanging out with computer nerds from
Silicon Valley to understand more about
the oceans to see more on the oceans and
to manage them more effectively I really
see technology as the keystone for being
able to figure out how to get to that
hundred year future that thousand year
future which is healthy for our oceans
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you